do you do covers when you do a two-hour
show yeah you're doing neil young now
huh yeah yeah what song do you do when
you uh
cover him after the gold rush oh no
kidding why why that one
you know it's funny i have a friend in
la and he wrote me one day and said
i was just listening to song and i think
you should do it when you decide to do
that song your friend suggested do you
sit there and go
uh gee now i got to work out an
arrangement do you start to change the
song around are you just literal
i think it's always bad if you do
literal right because you can never do
it like they do it and you're singing to
a song in your head
yeah and it's you and you start here
you're never going to be better than the
original
ever so do you try to learn the chords
as he played them or you do your own i
do my own verse
yeah i'm sure i'm messing something up
but i try to make it personal yeah
you know almost like a it's like
recounting a story
it's like a memory and you're trying to
find what you like about the memory and
then when you can make it personal then
every time you tell it that emotion
comes through
if you try to be you know like a
sycophant like you know
every note is precious and when neil
held the note four seconds
right neil would laugh at that like i
think right
i i agree like like what i just went in
the studio one day and i did it and i
i would do it different every time you
know what i mean can't yeah because it
would be karaoke it's not the testament
you know it's
yeah let me hear a little sure again
i'll shut up you seem to know what
you're doing
[Music]
well i dreamed i saw the night's
[Music]
there were pleasants singing in dramas
drumming
in the archer spit the trees
there was a fan film blowing to the sun
that was floating on the brims
looking mother nature on the run
in the 20s
looking mother nature on the
run in the 2017
[Music]
i was lying in a burned-out basement
with the full moon in my eyes
i was hoping for a placement
when the sun was through the sky
it was
[Music]
i was thinking about what a friend that
said
[Music]
well i dreamed i saw the silver
spaceships
lying in the yellow haze of the sun
there were children flying in colors
flying
all around the chosen ones
all in a dream
[Music]
in the sun flying mother nature silver
sea
to a new home
jeez i love that